hey what's up guys my name is achernar
welcome to episode 21 of game
programming okay so yesterday we took a
look at actually creating the sprite
class which is really cool and is the
basis for all future sprites for our
game now today we're actually gonna take
it a bit slower because yesterday I
really felt that I sort of jammed in all
this when I originally started the
series I intended to do like a couple
lines of code each video I did like
freakin 27 yesterday so yeah I'm going
to be taking them bit slower a bit more
in depth so that you guys can really you
know understand
um and because do you know that is
really the purpose of this series so
okay so we've got the sprite class now
how do we actually create sprites with
it now the way we're going to do it is
basically legitimately create a sprite
so let's open on paint.net this is our
sprite sheet sprite sheet or PNG that we
created last episode oh sorry two
episodes ago so episode 19 we actually
created this bright sheet dot PNG file
and with a grid all right so if we go
into a grid here we're just gonna create
a sprite like right over here um because
and this is just going to be temporary
so what we'll do is we will lit I'll
just like you guys can create whatever
artwork you want I'm not going to spend
too much time on artwork that isn't the
purpose of the series but I'm going to
create a nice grass here um maybe a bit
ah um and
actually that should prove the lighter
nice um
[Music]
for us oops
all right so that's legitimately my
grass for now just go with it so we've
created a grass texture right now and
we'll just save it how do we actually
use this grass texture in Java in our
game and the way we do that is pretty
simple we actually need to create a
sprite out of it now you might be like
hang on you're creating a sprite in the
sprite class how does that work well
it's very simple because the thing is
sprites for us are going to be static
because they will not change will they
no they won't
once you define a sprite it will stay
the same so let's just go public public
static sprite so we're creating a new
sprite object right here in sprite class
and we'll call it grass and we'll
actually set it equal to new sprite so
we're creating a new sprite and then
we've got to fill out all of these
things the first of all how big is it
it's 16 right that's the size is 16 by
16 pixels x and y are 0 and 0 because
it's in the top left corner of this grid
and the sprite sheet is actually we kind
of need to create that one so for now
we'll probably just type in currently
tab in shape for the sprite sheet we
might just leave that
[Music]
Nicorette the spritesheet first so for
now we're going to leave it as null all
right obviously that's not a good idea
but for now we'll leave it as null
because we haven't actually created the
sprite sheet yet but this line of code
guys is what you really need to actually
learn and the reason is this is what
will actually create our sprite okay if
we were to reference it from a different
class we would simply type sprite dot
grass and that's it that will give us
this texture now how does this work
first of all again it creates a new
static version of this prior new static
instance of the sprite class now
remember every instance of the sprite
class has unique variables all of these
because none of them is static it has a
unique size it's got a unique coordinate
it's got a unique pixel array which
means that when we access sprite grasses
pixels right because again we're
creating a new sprite object so it
contains everything that's in this class
except for this because it's static when
we when we create that we actually go
through all this process we load the
appropriate texture the appropriate
texture or sprite into the pixel array
so that when we then access sprite grass
dot pixels it refers to the appropriate
pixels because this is the grass object
and we've taught we've told it to load
at this coordinate all right so go
through this make sure you know this
code because that is how we will create
sprites from now on that is how we will
use sprites from now on as well and and
yeah so once again besides we've
specified the size of specified the
corner of it if this was say whoops if
this was for example oops
if this was for example over here
instead of up there we would have to go
zero one and I hope you understand that
because that's like zero that's the x
value and y is 1 so Y is 1 down so that
is that is how that works all right
that's how you create a new sprite and
tomorrow we'll actually take a look at
create actually creating the sprite tree
because at the moment null isn't
acceptable I just completely forgot that
we hadn't created a sprite sheet yet so
we will have to create a spreadsheet and
we'll do that in tomorrow's episode so I
hope you enjoyed the episode guys if you
did please hit the like button let me
know what you thought in the comments
and I will see you guys tomorrow with a
brand new episode of Gabriel ramming
until then guys goodbye
[Music]
you